what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime outboard and this is it the
second great war in boku no hero is here
and this is very likely the end the
final showdown in the entire series
shigaraki is recovered and back in
action the number one hero waifu is also
recovered and back in action the
strongest heroes and the strongest
villains are about to clash in a battle
to the death and the hype is real you
guys know the drill just leave a quick
like and comment if you enjoy our videos
and you want to help us with that
youtube algorithm and of course don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it actually helps me out a
lot you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror finally this
video will of course contain boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned so the
previous chapter was a big setup for the
final war arc the epic ultimate showdown
between the heroes and the villains the
class 1a students said their goodbyes
izawa's plan was put into motion and in
the latest chapter it all goes down hard
we started off with all for one
revealing that back when quirks were
still new to the world he managed to
steal a quirk that allowed him to tell
whether someone he is speaking to has
even the slightest sliver of malicious
intent towards him this quirk works kind
of like a lie detector if anyone is
being nice to his face but plotting
something against him behind his back
all for one will be able to tell the
truth just by talking to the person you
can imagine how useful such a quirk
could be to an evil mastermind like all
for one and apparently the person from
whom all for once stole this quirk is an
ancestor of tsukauchi since it is widely
believed that tsukauji has a lie
detector type quirk and his sister is
revealed to have a quirk called
polygraph in the vigilantes manga all
for one is making full use of this quirk
while he is speaking to aoyama and his
mother over the phone they are speaking
in code but the plan is to use aoyama to
trick deku separate him from the other
heroes and bring him straight to all for
one and the villains now all for one
seems to be aware that aoyama and his
parents were captured by the heroes and
that they were interrogated however he
believes that they have been set free
presumably because the heroes couldn't
really prove anything and since all for
one doesn't sense any ill intention or
deception from aoyama and his mother he
seems confident that they are telling
the truth the next day we see deku and
aoiyama standing outside a big parking
garage in an abandoned section of a city
deku and ayam are going through the
motions of pretending that deku just
happened to come here after aoyama
invited him and then aoyama proceeds to
tell deku about all for one's true goal
back when the leaks were coming out to
this chapter some people were saying
that they actually thought that aoyama
was betraying deku but i think it was
pretty clear from the start that that
was not going to happen anyway now that
society has basically collapsed under
the weight of all this unprecedented
villain activity the japanese yen has
tanked and almost every japanese company
is going under this severe social
instability is only encouraging the
villains to be even more active and this
has led to a deadly spiral that is
spreading all over the world aoyama
compares the current situation to the
great depression or to the era of chaos
and confusion that followed the first
appearance of quirks and once the
situation gets bad enough in all the
countries of the world no one will have
the resources or the will to help japan
they will all be too busy trying to keep
their own countries and economies in one
piece aoyama then tells deku to imagine
what would happen if in such a difficult
situation where there may be no drinking
water or gas or electricity or other
basic needs a man appears who possesses
quirks that can provide drinking water
electricity gas and many other things
for them the desperate people would
flock to this one man as their savior
and hero and that one man would then be
able to shape society and maybe even the
entire world in whichever way he pleases
that is what all for one intends to do
he wants to drive japan to the brink of
collapse and then he plans to use his
many quirks to present himself as the
savior of japan who can solve all of the
people's problems the japanese people
would then flock to him and he would be
able to seize complete power in japan
and maybe even in the entire world this
makes sense and it is all really
interesting because quirks aside this is
definitely how things have worked in the
past in our own world in times of great
crisis and desperation people often
flock to strong leaders who promise to
solve their problems we saw this with
many revolutions and power grabs in
history including the prominent examples
of like russia germany and italy between
the two world wars there are many many
other examples of course leading all the
way back to ancient times but you guys
get the point and even if the leader who
is making all these promises is an
authoritarian who wants to take away the
people's rights and freedoms they are
still willing to follow him because they
are just so desperate they want to find
someone anyone who can help them find a
solution to their problems so all for
one appears to be following a playbook
that has worked time and time again in
our own world it is literally a plan for
world domination and after explaining
all of that to deku ayam apologizes with
tears in his eyes and says that in the
end he really wanted to make sure that
his mother and father were safe in that
moment a levitating all for one appears
behind aoyama and deku appears shocked
all for one thanks aoyama for delivering
deku as promised and he says that
aoyama's ability to betray his friends
has surpassed even his own expectations
and while all for one does say that
aoyama's explanation for his plans
wasn't completely accurate he still
applauds him for that little speech but
then a crying aoyama makes his move
calling over one his dear uncle which is
how he referred to him in code during
their secret communications aoyama turns
around and blasts his navel laser right
into all for one the laser lands a hit
but it doesn't seem to have done much
damage to over one who calls aoyama an
ungrateful wretch now random thought but
i've never heard anyone under the age of
60 use the word wretch so i think that
the translation here is trying to remind
us of just how old all for one really is
he's been alive for many many
generations deku then confirms that this
was all just an act in order to lure all
for one out of hiding and that aoyama
did a great job playing his part
meanwhile aoyama says his tears were
real because he was truly scared
throughout the entire thing and he even
managed to pee himself in the process
that is
great anyway in order to protect his
parents and his friends aoyama is
willing to push through his fear and
fight all for one and the villains this
is definitely a big big moment for
aoyama his redemption moment and i look
forward to seeing what he does in the
future for his part all for one is both
disappointed and confused by all of this
how did both aoyama and his mom managed
to lie to all for one during their phone
calls when all for one has a quirk that
is supposed to tell him when someone is
deceiving him this is a very interesting
question and i will come back to it
later in terms of actually being
physically there with deku you can argue
that aoyama never directly talked to all
for one until he used naval laser
against him so maybe that is why all for
one couldn't tell that he was actually
deceiving him but those phone
conversations where aoyama and his
mother were talking to everyone directly
are a different story and i will talk
about that in a little bit all for one
decides that there is no time to worry
about that now anyway because regardless
of the trickery he still has deku within
his grasp all for one unleashes that
warping sludge quirk that johnny the
nomu had and suddenly shigaraki dobby
toga and a bunch of other villains
appear in front of all for one this
actually includes some villains that i
don't recall seeing before so finding
out who they are and what their quirks
are is going to be interesting all for
one is confident that the heroes just
made a big mistake because even though
they tried to set him up they shouldn't
have let deku get so close to him on top
of that all the most powerful heroes
that the villains had faced in the past
are miles away from this spot so that
means that even if they leave now they
will not be able to make it in time to
help deku all for one is able to confirm
that this is the case by using ragdoll's
stolen quirk search but that is when
isabel's secret master plan comes into
play just as all for one is thinking
that stealing one for all is within his
grasp a bunch of portals begin to open
and it is clear that these portals are
being generated by kurogiri's quirk
gate all for one is surprised that the
heroes are managing to use kurogiri's
quirk but on the bright side this might
be an opportunity for him to actually
retrieve kurogiri however we soon
learned that it is not kurogiri who is
using warp gate it is actually nato
monoma copying warp gate and thanks to
monoma's warp gate portals a bunch of
heroes suddenly appear beside deku and
aoyama including those powerful heroes
that offer one thought were many miles
away we have endeavour headshot sun
eater washu negrechan gang orca a bunch
of others but most importantly of all we
have my wife miroko back in action
yes boys yes best girl is back and she
looks like she has fully recovered from
the injuries that she sustained back in
jakku and no axel don't you dare don't
you dare make any edits about miracle
not really being best girl because it's
toga i will i i won't do anything you do
great work but still don't do it man
[Music]
miroku now looks like she has a
prosthetic arm that has been turned into
some sort of powerful weapon so it could
actually make her even stronger and as
you would expect from my waifu miracle
she is front and center and leading the
charge against the villains and on that
epic note is how the chapter ends with
the heroes declaring that there is still
hope for japan and they are that hope if
they can save japan here and now then
they can also save the rest of the world
from all for one's evil plans the final
battle the final war between the heroes
and villains is already freaking here
this was insane so much hype in a single
chapter and the hype is only going to
grow from here i mean think about it the
stakes couldn't possibly be any higher
the top heroes and the top villains are
about to face off with the fate of japan
on the line and whatever happens in
japan is also going to have a profound
effect on what happens in the rest of
the world and yes i know that we still
haven't seen hawks and genus but i am
sure that they also have a role to play
in this fight but they may be holding
back for now as part of izawa's plan
honestly this is a huge development the
beginning of a brand new war arc and
there are a bunch of things that we need
to talk about first up how did aoyama
and his mother manage to trick all for
one despite the fact that he has a lie
detector quirk the chapter doesn't quite
explain what happened but if i had to
guess i would say that shinzo was
probably involved maybe shinso used his
persona chords to imitate the voices of
aoyama and his mother on the phone with
all for one so when we saw aoyama and
his mom talking to all for one they were
actually telling shinzo what to say and
then shinzo was saying it back to all
for one in their voices and if shinso
doesn't really understand that coded
language that all for one and the
aoyamas were using and maybe he doesn't
even know who he's talking to then he
wouldn't have any ill intent or
deception in his voice because he simply
wouldn't know what is being talked about
that is just my own speculation about
how this might have been accomplished
because shinso was clearly shown to be
involved in this plan in some way but
we'll have to wait and see
now we need to talk about nato whose
quirk copy allows him to copy and
possess up to four quirks but he can
only use them for about 10 minutes after
that he would have to touch the original
quirk user again before he can keep
using the quirk we know that nato can't
copy accumulation type quirks but he was
able to copy warp gate and used it
masterfully to bring the heroes onto the
battlefield and catch all for one by
surprise but is this nato's only role in
the fight or does he have more tricks up
his sleeve what other quirks do you
think that he might have copied and how
is he going to potentially use them
against the villains let me know what
you think about that down in the
comments below finally we also need to
talk about what happens now in the mha
story we are in a crucial moment for the
story the beginning of a new and quite
possibly the final massive war arc it's
hard to imagine where the story could
possibly go from here after this arc
comes to an end the stakes are just so
high right now all the strongest
villains and heroes are involved the
fate of all of japan and the entire
world is at stake and this really feels
like it's going to be the final arc i
mean there may still be more battles
after this particular battle but it's
hard to imagine that anything could
possibly top this high stakes showdown
so it makes sense that horikoshi called
this the final act of the series so is
this it is this the beginning of the end
for the entire mha story will there be
an arc after this arc or are we
witnessing the final chapters of boku no
hero unless we're gonna meet like alien
villains with cool space quirks it's
hard to imagine any scenario that can
top the stakes of this arc another
option might be like a time skip that
sees our main characters getting older
and a new generation of ua students
coming on the scene such as koda and
arie but i don't know as much as i'd
like to think that the story will
continue this really feels like it might
be the end do you guys agree can this
story continue in some way after this
arc will we get a sequel or a spin-off
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below if you guys
enjoyed this pocono hero video and you
want to see more in the future just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
that youtube algorithm and if you're new
to anime opera or maybe you've been
watching our videos for a while but you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a quick favor and make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications it is a completely free
and important way of supporting the
channel here on youtube i'm not just
asking you that to ask you subscribing
really does help you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at animeopror i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord to ego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one and tear patrons the
ones who rise above all other clans
including alpha sigma in grata algetal
pate hepha the red haired fox hinokami
and water the toasted chi corey mcgowan
spidey left tanel tungsten tarkis big
buddhist and jeremy cummings finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz alicia
ochter bonnie parks joy and garcia fat
boy games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips and alivania if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you